we agree that the best way to sustain  the global economic recovery is by  focusing on jobs and growth that's what  I'm focused on in the United States on  Friday we learned that our economy  created another 280,000 jobs in May the  strongest strongest month of the year so  far and more than 3 million new jobs  over the past year nearly the fastest  pace in over a decade we've now seen  five straight years of private sector  job growth 12.6 million new jobs created  the longest streak on record the  unemployment rate is near its lowest  level in seven years wages for American  workers continue to rise and since I  took office the United States has cut  our deficit by two-thirds so in the  global economy America is a major source  of strength